la posición de la comisión europea es
firme no se puede revisar el acuerdo
comercial post pre éxito sobre la
frontera con la irlanda del norte
londres había lanzado este lunes una
revisión unilateral bruselas contestó
con procesos judiciales contra el país
colts speights spect crisis y liga es
ilegal el proyecto de la ley británica
es extremadamente perjudicial para la
confianza mutua se ha creado una
profunda incertidumbre y ha enturbiado
nuestra cooperación mundial en un
momento en el que el cumplimiento de los
acuerdos internacionales nunca ha sido
tan importantes servín more importante
cuando reino unido dejó la unión europea
ambas partes acordaron mantener la
frontera terrestre entre la república de
irlanda e irlanda del norte si impuestos
de aduanas una condición esencial en el
proceso de paz que puso fin a décadas de
violencia en la región para proteger el
mercado único de la unión europea
londres y bruselas habían acordado
realizar controles de determinadas
mercancías el proyecto de ley de boris
johnson propone ahora de eliminar
algunos de esos controles afirmando que
pusieron a irlanda en desventaja
debido a la burocracia aduanera hemos
visto menos mercancías entrar en irlanda
del norte las hemos visto más caras y
también hemos visto como las empresas
británicas no comercian
bruselas anunció la apertura de dos
nuevos procedimientos por incumplimiento
de los controles de mercancías y el
relanzamiento de un tercero suspendido
en septiembre de 2021 por violación del
protocolo esto puede dar lugar a un
recurso ante el tribunal de justicia de
las comunidades europeas y a sanciones